tomas dropped off two packages to be
shipped
one package weighed 1.38
kilograms and the other package weighed
720 grams so the first one the given
kilograms and the second one they give
us in grams
what was the combined weight of both
packages in grams so what i want to do
is i'm going to convert both of these to
grams and then add them up to get the
combined weight well we already know the
second one is
720 grams but what's the first one in
terms of grams
well let's see 1.38
i could write kilograms like that
well if one kilogram is one thousand
grams and that's what the prefix kilo
means it means a thousand well to go
from one to one point three eight i'm
multiplying by one point three eight
so i'm also if i wanted in terms of
grams i would take a thousand grams and
multiply by 1.38
so this is going to be 1000 times 1.38
is 1380
grams which i could have just denoted
with a g
but now let's add those together this is
the first package and the second package
is
grams
and so if i were to add
this is going to be let's see
10.
let's see 4 plus 7 is 11
and then 1 plus 1 is 2 we get 2
100 grams in total let's do another one
of these unit conversion
examples
julia and her friends are making kites
out of paper
for each kite they need a piece of paper
that is
0.65 meters wide
how many centimeters how many
centimeters of paper will they need to
make four kites
so they tell us how wide the p paper is
in meters for each kite but they want
the answer in centimeters and they want
it for four kites
so let's think about this a little bit
each kite is
0.65 meters
0.65 meters so to go from 1 to 0.65 you
multiply by
0.65 on the meters and so to go to 100
centimeters to the number of centimeters
you would need for the width of a kite
you'd similarly multiply by 0.65
well 65 hundredths times 100 is going to
be 65
65 centimeters per kite so this is 0.65
meters wide per kite in centimeters it
is 65
centimeters
now they don't want just how much paper
will they need to make one kite they
want four kites
so we would multiply this times four
this is how much we need per kite so
let's multiply that times four
and so let's see four times five is
twenty
four times six is 24 plus two
is 26 260 centimeters of paper for the
width of the four kites
let's do one more of these
this is a volume conversion
omar is pouring
five liters of water into two goldfish
bowls he spills 200 milliliters of water
and then divides the remaining water
evenly between the two bowls
how many milliliters
of water does omar pour into each bowl
so we want our answer at the end in
milliliters and so let's just convert
the amount that he starts with into
milliliters so he starts with five
he starts
with five
liters so how many milliliters is that
going to be
well they tell us 1 liter is 1 000
milliliters so if we have 5 liters so
we're multiplying our quantity times 5
it's going to be 5 times
it's going to be
5 times as many milliliters
so that's thousand times five is five
thousand
milli
liters
so that's what he starts with now before
he splits this five thousand milliliters
between
between these two bowls he spills 200
milliliters so let's subtract out what
he spills because he that's not going to
be able to be split
milliliters
and so that's going to give us
so we're going to have 4 800 milliliters
to split between those two bowls
and so each bowl that's what they're
asking us how many milliliters of water
does he pour into each bowl well if he's
going to split this into two bowls each
bowl is going to get half of this
and so each bowl is going to get
half of 4 800 so we just divide that by
two so each bowl is going to get 2400
milliliters
2400 milliliters and 2400
milli
liters
that's how much each bowl is going
that's how much omar is going to pour
into each bowl